How Tongle works for your invitees
depends on if you've invited one or many
people. Let's look at one
invite. Your invite receives an email
meeting invitation and clicks to see the
times that you've
proposed. All they have to do is pick
the one time that works for
them and book the
meeting. They submit and they never have
to sign up.
Now, let's look at a group
meeting. Again, each inviteee receives
an email invitation. They click to see
your
times, and this time they select all the
times that work for
them. Once they're
happy, they submit their
availability again. They never have to
sign
up. Once a meeting is
booked, each inviteee receives an email
confirmation. If they're a Tunnel
Member, the meeting is automatically
added to their calendar. If they're not
a
member, they simply click the link to
add it to their own calendar.